dan she says it's a false choice that
you don't have to hurt the police when
you defund
them okay listen uh liberals are real
they're full of dumb ideas okay we get
that i mean when you think even just in
the past week
so joe biden he wants to he you know he
canceled the keystone pipeline so they
dumped a bunch of energy jobs here
while simultaneously building out the
russian pipeline to make putin richer
they also want to teach us to remedy
past discrimination by teaching kids now
to discriminate so liberals are full of
dumb ideas but having said that
to defund the police movement i'm not
kidding was these
triaging the dumb ideas was the single
dumbest idea
they have ever had and you can tell they
know it
because they're trying to now blame
republicans for it which is hilarious
like you have to be a dunce with a with
a dunce cap sitting in the corner to
actually believe this stuff
but a couple things here they realize
they made a mistake because now going
forward pete
they put themselves in a box they're
pushing a bill right now
this affh program affirmatively
furthering fair housing what does that
have to do with defunding the police
it will literally rip money away from
localities
if you don't put section 8 type housing
in the suburbs
that will actually defund the police
they're pushing that right now
while claiming the republicans are doing
this and i confronted
my guest last week on about unfiltered
how do you support that
and then claim the republicans are
defunding the police but this is going
to be a disaster for them in the
midterms
because public safety is the one issue
guys that hit you with the kitchen table
you can argue all you want about tax
rates but god forbid your kid gets
mugged or your car gets broken into
that issue becomes personal it bleeds
for you right there and they know
they're in trouble
the numbers back you up on this here's
the percentage of people who support the
idea of deploying more police officers
into the streets it's 77
70 of people support increasing police
department
budgets you know the 2020 election dan
was so much
about personalities it was so much
honestly about president donald trump
and what that covers up is that the
ideas as you point out not just defund
the police i would contend but many many
more ideas
are incredibly unpopular the idea that
the left has been championing
you point to 2022 what's coming ahead
you know
i think sometimes we worry about our
culture and our country and we should
it may be that there's a ray of hope
that there's some positive
insight here that the public does not
want these ideas that did not get a
sufficient hearing in the past couple of
years
yeah see that's the thing about you know
with liberal issues versus conservative
issues some of them you see
everyday kitchen table voters who you
know they can't get lost in the wonkery
they have you know they have to go to
work they have to go to their kids
soccer games
if the tax rates go up a few you know
points here or there
yeah maybe it affects them maybe it
doesn't they'll catch their accountant
at the end of the year
you know they're paying it every week in
a check they barely see it's direct
deposited
but that's not the case with this issue
when it comes to crime
it happens in front of you in your face
everybody that's why coronavirus guys
honestly was such a big issue
everybody knew someone who had it that's
the problem with crime and i lived
through it in new york city
when rudy giuliani in a major upset won
the mayorship
twice because crime was hitting people
in their own
homes they can't run from this you're so
right dan in new york i swear
the city is just so different over the
last six seven years
the whole place smells like i'm sorry it
smells like urine and pot and there's
you know there's crime everywhere it's
just disgusting um no don't be sorry
i hate saying it and it's and it's gross
yeah
it's disgusting it's the greatest city
on earth yeah they should treat it as
such and they don't yeah
so really quick i want to get to this
because this is another kitchen table
issue which is jobs and i've been
watching
your show i've been loving it you talked
about this issue
and i think you hit the nail on the head
and that is that a lot of people are
getting paid right now by
our government not to go to work
businesses are hurt wherever you go the
service is bad
people can't find enough people to work
and yet there's all these job openings
i want to just i don't want to talk
about how stupid the policy is
i want to talk about or have you talk
about what is it doing to
our culture to the work ethic in this
country
yeah i mean that matters i did i i
opened up with my show unfiltered last
week talking about exactly this
yeah you know guys on a very serious
note and you know we laugh a lot on this
and
you know we we laugh and we have
emotional issues we talk about this is
serious
it's not just that paying people not to
work is not compassionate okay that
it's not it's outright evil
you know it's the difference between
malfeasance and misfeasance right
like you see someone fall on a sidewalk
you don't help them up you know it's
misfeasing she didn't do anything
malfeasance is when you walk by and you
punch them in the face as they try to
get up
there are different levels of depravity
there what does that mean in regards to
this rachel i'm glad you brought this up
when you rob people of the dignity of a
job by
incentivizing them and paying them to
stay home not all will but a lot will
people aren't stupid some people are
rational maximizers i can make more stay
at home so i will
you rob them of everything the
experience of socializing with other
human beings
the as milton friedman said the ability
to manipulate your environment and learn
the value of
work to produce something of value guys
listen
i cleaned mausoleums in a cemetery i
clean toilet bowls in a key food
you laugh all you want i that was the
cleanest damn toilet bowl you ever saw
and the cleanest mausoleum because i
understood
that that's what i was paid to do and
that cemetery i worked in needed that
and i was going to add value and when
you rob people of the dignity of that
you've stolen every part of being human
the ability to live on this planet
and leave one day and say you know what
it's better because i was here
it is evil it's not just not
compassionate
it's evil and wrong could not agree with
you more
well said this is why this is why you
have a show unfiltered with dan bongino
and people love it
what do you have on the program dan i'm
stoked about tonight's show by the way
you
had jesse on before i have jesse on
tonight did you catch jesse's joke about
performance-enhancing pills i don't know
if you guys caught that i caught it i
watched your show
he's on tonight i have a video with
jesse i promise it's a huge surprise
we catch him totally off guard with this
he has no idea it's coming
i got that i got irish mickey ward
former boxing champ
talking about persistence great movie
made about him and a fantastic interview
with drago desarian
a navy seal immigrant to this country i
saw him on jocko willing's podcast
it's spectacular the guy's going to blow
your mind i promise you're going to love
it
awesome we'll be watching thanks so much
dan always great
thank you thanks guys great talking to
you next week